new movie tag people people love this
film it hasn't even come out yet but all
the reviews are like through yes reviews
you don't use I haven't seen the movie
yet you haven't seen the movie no I
don't really like watching myself I get
very I judge this up crap out of
myself what are you talking about
Hardwick came out here he's got like 9
yeah he had someone filling a Tesla with
semen and then you're all you need is a
hundred bucks and Craigslist and you can
get anything done that's the sentence
turbine said before we have a clip here
from Tang it's a very funny idea for a
movie which is a bunch of friends have
been playing tag for one month of the
year and this is based on a true story
so true so it sounds crazy but it's it's
wonderful they've been doing this as I
feel like they were like 7 yes and now
it's it's it's gotten to the point where
there's one of them that's never been
tagged play by jeremy renner my
husband-to-be it's my wedding
yep and these Hojo's are about to ruin
my wedding yeah they want to get in
there and they want to try and ruin it
we have a clip here from tag let's take
a look
so glad you made it
are we cool yeah yes yeah sorry
not cool yet okay Jerry has a perfect
record and we're a team now
the winning team and I just feel like
hoagie if you're gonna play a children's
game as a grown man maybe next time
don't play like a child anyways I am
really excited you guys are here try the
raw bar it's off the hook
tag is in theaters June 15th and people
think it's hilarious so I think you're
in good shape
leslie bibb we're right back comedian
Nuria Davis is here
you